so we at station Q and Microsoft are
really excited about this liquid
challenge we've built liquid with the
hopes of educating a quantum community
and bringing tools into the hands of the
world's future quantum mechanics
challenge entries should come from
individuals or from teams of up to three
people and should really be novel
creative and cutting-edge we hope to
discover new ways of using liquid or
even new ways to use quantum computers
so we've already used liquid in a
variety of ways we've used it to
validate the performance of quantum
error correction protocols to determine
circuit optimizations for quantum
chemistry algorithms develop new
algorithms with which to instantiate
quantum Oracle's to understand the
performance of magic state distillation
under noise and to produce better
gradients for machine learning using
quantum circuits we've decided how many
qubits a cryptographic protocol might
require to be broken using liquid and
well a lot of other applications entries
can cover a variety of areas and in
particular should use liquid to offer a
new solution to a problem contain a
non-trivial amount of code offer
insights into an area of research these
areas of research can be quantum
algorithms quantum error correction
noise modeling debugging quantum
information theory really the sky is the
limit we're anxious to see what all of
you come up with